now here are going to do something weird
and just like proof by contradiction you
know how there was an assumption built
into it remember that I'm going to have
another assumption built into this but
it's a different kind I'm going to
assume that the statement is true for
some random value of M okay so because I
I want to pick a value of n what I do is
I give that a letter so I'm going to
call by particular value of M okay so
I'm going to assume that this number
here is divisible by 3 now I want to do
this in an algebraic way so that I can
start to manipulate this thing so if you
have a look at our numbers over here
that if it's divisible by 3 what are the
things you notice is that you can write
every single one of these numbers I'm
going to use another color as 3 times a
whole number do you agree with that so
for example what is 423 divided by 3
what is it 141 right that's 141 times 3
yeah I'm going to skip down to here 210
is 70 so this is negative 69 times 3
yes so I'm gonna help me out one of
these these are three times something
right what are they eight million eight
hundred and fifty six thousand six
hundred and one times three and really
that work where does this dirty come
from I'll be sure
is 11 aha okay right that's fine
86 and 50 mm he's got this one this is
work that I just write a battery for me
just tell me what it is
wait 11 11 yep
317 71 times three okay great so in
other words if a number is divisible by
3 then you should be able to say you
should be able to write it as 3 times
something else and that should be a
whole number
okay so I'm going to say therefore that
this on the key if it really is
divisible by 3 I should be able to say
it's equal to 3 times some other number
where that thing's a whole number
okay now I've just introduced the bunch
of letters and so I need to say what
kinds of numbers they are because
they're not just any random number this
is not true if P is like five and a half
P is five and a half then this number is
not divisible by three that's be a whole
lotta right and it's the same deal with
K Caves like n so it has to follow the
same rules so I'm going to say where K
has to be a positive integer
just like n does you see how sitting in
the same spot as Eddie's and P actually
is just an integer I'm okay if that's
negative as you can see like over here
okay so I make this assumption right and
now here comes the mathematical part of
the mathematical induction I don't need
to prove something related to this
statement namely that the next statement
is also true okay now let me explain is
because this is a bit weird why am I
doing this right excuse me this is I'm
assuming it's true for some value of K
maybe I assume it's true for like a
hundred now I want to prove that it's
true for the next value so you can see
if I want to go from this value K so the
next one I just go k plus 1 do you see
what I've done there alright so I'll
just substitute k plus 1 everywhere that
I've got this here so I'm assuming that
it's
true for this value of n and now I want
to prove that it's true for the next
value of M does that make sense that's
why I add one okay and in the same way
I've just introduced the letter so I'd
better say what it is okay so how do I
do this this takes a bit of imagination
once you see how to do this particular
problem because this is a category of
problem is ability to visibility problem
every time you see a division probably
in the future you can use something like
this but there are more kinds of things
are just two visibility that you can
prove by mathematical induction so
therefore you need to think about these
a bit carefully and there's plenty of
examples in the book you can work
through